[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul aka the biggest wickhead
on YouTube and this video we're going to
be talking about a number of things that
we've learned about John Wick chapter 4.
in this video I'm going to be breaking
down the alternate ending that they
considered using and also how the cast
and crew reacted to Lance reddick's
passing I just want to get straight into
it but as we're going to be talking
about the original ending we have to
give a spoiler alert before we get into
it this scene was shot as an add-on to
what we saw at the end and it may ruin
the film if you haven't had a chance to
check it out yet all out the way huge
thank you for clicking this now let's
get into John Wick chapter 4. now the
movie ends with Jon killing the Marquee
but in order to do that he has to get
him into taking part in the jewel itself
in his arrogance once he sees that John
is seemingly beaten he decides to take
Kane's weapon and he goes to shoot Jon
Wick didn't actually fire during the
last shot though and he uses this
opportunity to kill the Marquee and free
not only himself but also Kane and his
daughter however he's mortally wounded
Annie ends up dying on the steps of the
church after uttering his wife's name
Helen now many people were shocked to
see this scene playing out as as Wick
was seen as this invincible and
Unstoppable Terminator that was the very
personification of the boogeyman like
Baba Yaga
[Music]
because of this many people have
speculated over the last couple of days
that Wick is still alive and there's
been a lot of wires getting crossed over
whether he'll return or not there was a
fifth John Wick film greenlit along with
four and because of that there's been
this talk that they haven't announced
that so people just go with the ending
Wick is also due to appear in the anode
armor spin off the ballerina and you can
see how rumors can spread
no not like Baba Yaga however Chad
stahlski has been doing a lot of press
over the last couple of days and he's
discussed an alternate ending they shot
which is actually cleared up a lot of
things so originally chapter 5 was in
the works and they were gonna shoot it
back to back with chapter four although
he said that they realized they'd rather
do one movie that they can put their all
into instead of just making two
concurrently the ballerinas also said
between the events of chapter three and
four so it doesn't really rack on the
ending of this film either now as of
that ending when the director and Keanu
went to the studio to pitch the idea
they kicked off and said they were
insane for killing off their big Cash
Cow in an interview with The Hollywood
Reporter Chad said that because of this
the crew ended up having to shoot an
alternate ending for the film and in
this Jon was left alive when discussing
it he said they were initially unsure
over whether to do a fourth movie and
they came up with the why which would
ultimately be Jon's death they realized
that they'd kind of fallen into a
formula with these movies where they
were the same sorts of Beats and Chad
even said that if he was a fan then he
would have watched chapter 3 thinking
how is he going to get out of this just
give me an ending so chapter 4 was
pitched as something that the franchise
hadn't tackled before which was
consequences and also a conclusion he
said that they very much felt like the
fun should be a goodbye to Jon but they
also wondered how to give a proper one
thus they came up with the idea that
slays throughout the movie which is that
a good death only comes after a good
life he says that sums up the film and
that the entire movie is about an
action-packed thrill Rider which Jon
gets his Redemption now Chad then went
into the test screenings that they did
and the times that they show the
alternate ending to audiences according
to the director the ending was almost
identical all the way up to the funeral
scene we even had that play out exactly
the same however Jon's dog would look
longingly over and from here we get to
confirm that Jon was still alive this is
why we had that shot in the movie and
also Winston and the Bowery King
discussing whether he was in heaven or
hell because they said neither that also
implied that he was still alive and out
there somewhere which is something that
we pointed out in our breakdown of the
movie which is linked to in the comment
below about the fact that Chad's saying
all these ideas were eventually cut down
means that the intention was indeed to
kill him so put away your tinfoil hats
you chump Jon is intended to be dead but
with Hollywood being Hollywood you never
know how they're gonna work this stuff
in so as Chumps keep going back I'm
talking the ballerina introducing
cloning technology or something now this
ending didn't go down too well either
not the cloning thing that the the
anyway still live and apparently after
the test screening they realized that it
wasn't a good fit but how they made
their movie everything about it is
centered around death and in bringing
back John it's somewhat cheaper than the
message they talked about how this film
was about him realizing that he'd ruined
many of his friends lives hadn't hit the
thumbs up button and had killed hundreds
and hundreds of people in order to
avenge his dog thus they wanted to give
him some finality and consequences to
that so they had him saving a friend
before his death which acted somewhat as
a redemption in the end the studio also
told them that they could go with
whatever ending they felt strongest
about and this is what we got in the
Final Cut with Jon passing away for now
anyway this film I'm sure you won't be
back but this film is of course filled
with death and sadly most notably
Sharon's played by Lance Reddick the
actor sadly passed away whilst the
creative team were promoting the film
and this has been a tragic conversation
topic centered around the movie Lance
died just as the film was being sent out
to press for screenings and she had
talked about with a creative team felt
upon learning this he said that both he
and Keanu were massive fans of the actor
because of the wire that he was one of
the first people I cast after getting
Keanu for the role he said that when
they initially pitched the idea for the
first film it was difficult getting
people to show interest because they
said it was about a man whose dog was
killed at Ernie got revenge didn't
really work in Pitch meetings he didn't
get the grand scale of it and this many
actors ended up turning it down however
they said to Lance you're gonna be Caron
the gatekeeper John Wick is gonna be
like Greek mythology it's a film like
Lord of the Rings but in modern day
apparently he instantly got it and
signed on to the movie now kitivore and
he said that when they pitched the Adida
Lance about his death that this was his
reaction look I can't tell you I love it
I can't tell you I'm not upset but I can
tell you that I don't know another way
to make this movie good Chad later went
on to talk about how his character's
death is the Catalyst in the movie that
really kicks things off and it's a major
driving force for Winston the Marquee
didn't want to make Winston Armada as it
would give people a reason to fight
other than killing Sharon he very much
made one for Winston now when talking
about his reaction to his death Chad
said cut to Last Friday but literally
just got off the plane in Toronto but it
seemed to be a very exciting and
positive time all his screenings had
been going really well and we'd been so
fortunate to have good responses so we'd
been talking to Lance probably every
other day and had just seen him during
the LA Press he left him with a high
five going catch you later and then when
we got off the plane Derek Holsted the
original writer who's very close with
Lance and his family called me and said
that Lance had passed away we hadn't
even put the bags in the room yet and I
made one call to Keanu Jan said and I
was like hey man I gotta come see you in
your room and he was like sure come up
so you opened the door and I was like
look I have some bad news Lance just
passed away now for the initial what the
shock everything went quiet then
Keanu looked to me and said this is for
him he only had two or three hours
before we had to go on stage in Toronto
and do the thing again but that's
obviously nothing compared to what his
family and close friends are going
through so for the next hour and a half
before our screening we told land
stories we realized how lucky we are to
have work with him it was one of the
most fortunate times of my life now the
movie had been sent out to Cinemas
already and they said it's extremely
difficult to recall at ecps that gets
sent out to theaters however even before
chetas line skater adds something to the
end the studio had been hard at work and
they'd been making the calls to try and
get it out there they said that
unfortunately not every single screening
will have their dedication added on to
the end but I saw it on mine I don't
know that others did too now Chad did
say that by the time it hit streaming
and so on that the dedication will be in
place and that they can make sure that
Lance is remembered for the great man
that he was and that concludes the video
and I hope you enjoyed this extra
information on the movie even if a lot
of it is to do with tragedy both on and
off the screen let me know your thoughts
below would you like to have seen the
alternate cut in the film or do you
prefer what we ended up getting comment
below and just let you know we are in a
competition right now giving the
Superman 4K box set to 3 subscribers on
the 15th of April all you have to do to
be on the chance of winning is like the
video make sure you subscribe and
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the video
repeat the comments out random on the 15
then the winners of the last one are on
screen right now save that to you then
message me until we're at heavy spoilers
he wants me out to watch them make sure
you check out our breakdown of the film
which will be linked on screen right now
lots of things to talk about that ending
the post credit scene and yeah
definitely head over there right after
this by the way thanks for sticking
through the video I've been poor I'll
see you next time take care peace